yesterday Ren posted a thread on the r /
chord or subreddit basically asking
people to share their thoughts about the
same an eco channel things they'd like
constricted like we got an overwhelming
response for people basically saying
they wanted to see more real true to
life behind the scenes content we really
want to acknowledge that and put some
effort into doing this so we take the
time I'm going to talk to you guys about
lifeline here we are at pipeline
production headquarters Sam and I are
cranking away time to get everything
ready to create two more days of prep
when we start shooting on Monday
shooting eight half-hour episode that's
240 minutes of content and generally one
script page equals one minute let's 240
pages of script so Sam and I are
currently still working on the script
you're subtracting to finalize on top of
that with a piece of pig you have a
person for every department just like
putting the whole thing together so we
have a whole art department with a bunch
of people working in the art department
all being headed up by one person you
have a bunch of people in the costume
department a bunch of people in the
makeup department camera department all
these different departments which
usually on a youtube shoot it be mean
Jake Sam and Jake but now it's like 30
people say nice to say very very focused
on just being directors and being here
to give people direction outline things
clarify them and make sure there's a bit
of a unified vision on top of everything
and that's why you guys haven't seen us
too much good Nick going through the
camera it's like not having me your
camera studio your random fight fires
fires like is this smoke coming out of
the server room behind my group stopped
wearing shirt really yeah there's like a
raccoon family this happen
how's it being a waste you know it's
kind of peaceful once an hour in the
studio we have to also like delegate
make sure that we're making salmon eco
videos just make sure we are writing and
working on corridor videos let's keep
working on all other projects also
around those and right now Sam and I
have one thing to do and that is make
lifeline that rate the studio it's like
good luck
I'll see you later together do one
session kind of nice like at this point
just getting our daily schedule laid out
for us a list of things to do and we
just have to go do it and that's it we
actually kind of get told what to do
kind of nice
waking up at like 6:00 a.m. that's been
the hardest thing so far you stay here
at all because I have not slept here yet
I'm going to do my best and never have
that happen because that means I've lost
control of my life I don't immediately
keep your slender neck gravity oh god
the worst chat ever Carmichael do you
remember when back in the day we stayed
if you got two videos I got a hundred
thousand views in two weeks you get a
new camera I just want to point out
we're getting on in two thousand views
on every video now come I go with last
night we get 200,000 views on two videos
in a few weeks
plastic camera I will go to buy a campus
oh yeah go for third wheel GPA did it
you're going to say buy a camera
no it would be like my you like a
lollipop you guys get to videos to get a
million views and fans two weeks
watching you camera boom for now - there
you go - nope just an arrow which again
yes that's right only goes on do we want
no it's given us for the watch yes okay
this is shot a7s on a run and redoing a
showery orbital bed away isn't something
the wife behind something there was like
what is that thing it's like a gyroscope
and like what running different wait how
do you still not know what him over they
can afford Steadicam yeah like a
Steadicam for hand what we're gonna talk
to our department but a lot of movies
you have to show computer screens phones
all kind of stuff paper you have to
develop your own UI or user interface
you can't always show Windows Mac OS 10
or whatever because of our copywriters
copywriting art so you can design your
own a lot of movies will use these
sci-fi you eyes just look really fancy
crazy gobbledygook flying all over the
screen just make it look fancy but in
this case we want to be able to tell a
story with this is just as much of a
tool as anything else for us to help dog
and understand what the heck is going on
in the world of lifeline then when you
just mash the auto suggested words but
I'm writing a message
right now let's do it so look at the new
hair and I hope you have it all day okay
let's have a conversation
so Apple has like the three words in
those common words we use after the next
word such like automatically generating
speech no I can get back from you guys
then I'll be happy sleep for a bit but I
guess I'll just sleep for now let me try
starting with a really weird word and
see could prompt other rivers associate
with it baseball season great season
going on yeah I'm in carpentry work you
robots should not let the people go what
candy crush is the best thing to do that
I can always be acres man don't get a
chance at the first place game but then
again it would just be a good idea to be
a good man YouTube hey you do video is a
good idea to be a good friend is a great
man a productive day
yeah okay so it's also like little
awesome and think about so I just sat
down and picked out ten different cards
for all the characters and the residue
that before look actually up with a
bunch of pictures and I point out which
one my wife I need a pickup truck
it looks scary and almost runs over one
of our characters Mosley is right over
here and I think I can see it right now
you see it's not like high enough not
like kind of comes up Phillies here on
amis like yeah copy
flex all troll be alright that'll work
i'ma get some options for every step and
we'll be back to show you okay cool
thank you bit this is pretty much our
day-to-day is same myself working on
scripts and every 15-20 minutes we can
find sit down in it and figure out a
problem and you want to measure so
problem solving that's all filmmaking is
problem solving that's it my character
is Fredrick du Brey I also carry an
ounce of halfling lease sell it on the
side it's not like that's
the endgame for me I'm obviously going
to get a better job in the future just
for now yeah give the money you know
strength in strength strength
intimidation